hey guys Pete here so a lot of people
were asking about the timeline in Twin
Peaks more and more so it seems that
it's out of line and because of this in
the last couple videos I had a lot of
questions in the comments so I don't
know exactly and I would say that no one
really knows exactly what if anything
this nonlinear narrative actually means
but it is clear that there are things
that happen out of order
luckily reddit user the cow jumped over
the M has done a pretty good job of
putting things together and that's what
I'm going to be using right now to go
through things if you're wondering how I
came up with this a lot of it has to do
with date clues that we got combining
that with the clothes people are wearing
and things like that now I'll link to
the original reddit post in the
description of this video and you can
see more about the methods there it's
not precise and some things are best
guesses but if you read through the
comments and you look at the different
inputs that he's had from other people
it's a pretty good working outline so
I'm going to start from the top and work
my way down and then I'll add some other
commentary at the end so in our timeline
the very first thing that we know of
that happened on a specific date is Phil
Hastings and Ruth Davenport going to the
zone for the second time this would be
when Ruth dies and when Briggs head
leaves his body and he goes up into the
air saying Cooper Cooper according to
what we know from his conversation with
Tammy this happened on the 22nd of
September and that's a Thursday
somewhere around the same time the
events that happened in the Red Room may
have gone down but there's no saying for
sure about that so I'm largely going to
leave that out of the timeline we do
know that there's the part where the
arms doppelganger sends Cooper into
non-existence but you know he passes
through the mob zone and all that other
stuff and we don't really know how time
works in those places so we all know
that stuff happened so let's just keep
that in mind the next day Friday the
23rd of September Davenport's body was
found we see detective matically show up
and on that same day mr. C picks up Rey
and Daria from beulas place also on that
day is the first day as we saw New York
City where Sam's watching the class
box and Tracy comes to bring him coffee
the next day Saturday the 24th bill
Hastings is arrested mr. C has dinner
with ray and Daria and then after that
we assume he went back and killed
Hastings wife also in New York that day
Tracy comes again with the coffee
Cooper flies through the box and because
no one's watching the outside Sam brings
Tracy in they have an encounter and end
up dead the next day would be Sunday the
25th of September and we see some things
in Twin Peaks for the first time see dr.
Jacoby at his compound there this would
be the day that Hawk opens up Laura's
murder case again like he gets the boxes
out and the day that Jerry comes to meet
Ben and he first meets Beverly on Sunday
the 25th we also have our first Las
Vegas interaction in that Duncan talking
to his assistant and we assume that he
hired Lorraine at this point back in
Buckhorn Constance finds the ring mr. C
kills Jack after he picks up the car ray
ends up getting sent to jail mr. C goes
back to the hotel
kills Darya and prepares to go to
Yankton himself on Monday the 26th
sheriff Truman comes into the office we
see Bobby cry when he sees Laura
Palmer's picture on the table dr.
Hampton has his broadcast where we see
Jerry watching it from the woods and
Wally Brando stops by the Sheriff's
Department in Las Vegas the switch
happens between dougie and the original
agent Cooper this is where he's with
Jade in the house we see him get saved
from assassination attempt I reaching
down for the key Jay drops him off at
the silver Mustang casino and he becomes
mr. jackpots
later on that same evening Dane EE gets
introduced when Doug is brought home on
the same day on the way to Yankton mr. C
crashes after avoiding the switch in his
car and he gets sent to jail over in
Philadelphia Cole finds out what's going
on and he goes and meets Denise that
very same day on Tuesday the 27th we see
the scene where Steven is out looking
for
job then they meet up in his car and
bike he gets high outside of the Double
R this would be where Jerry's lost and
he calls Ben that night we find out that
Richard and Chad are working together
deputy Chad and that's when he would
have scared those two girls in Las Vegas
Lorraine sends the text Cooper has his
first morning where he has coffee again
later in that same day we state see Jade
mail the room key dougie coupe goes into
the office for the first time and then
across town his car explodes outside of
the one-one-nine girl's house we see the
Mitchum's at the silver Mustang and
they're upset because of the money that
they lost to dougie coupe and at home he
brings his case files there and he's
working on them when he gets a little
earful from Jamie II on that same day in
Yankton the FBI arrives at the jail
meets with Cooper they have that Blue
Rose conversation afterwards between
Albert and Gordon where he tells Albert
to go find we realize laters Diane we
see mr. C on the same day evil tip he
has Bob still inside him in the mirror
and then we see evil coupe make his call
where the cow jumped over the moon comes
into it on the very same evening Albert
goes to find Diane and on that same day
we see Colonel Davis at the Pentagon
send Knox over to Buckhorn and as
Cooper's making that phone call evil
Cooper's making that phone call we see
that box thing in Buenos Aires turn into
a pebble or whatever happened there on
the next day Wednesday the 28th of
September we see red he does his magic
trick for Richard after he leaves
Richard runs over the kid which call rod
and Miriam both witness at the Sheriff's
Department Hawk Pines and missing diary
pages sheriff Truman calls up doc
Hayward over the Great Northern venom
Beverly hear that hum and before they
leave she hands the key that came in the
mail for the room and we see some more
of Chad being a douchebag at the
Sheriff's Department that day as well in
Las Vegas the police show up to look
into the car explosion Duncan Todd sends
the envelope over to hi
right to kill Lorraine Bushnell had
looked over the case files again and
understands what Doug is trying to tell
him later in that same day I go to kill
the rain
Janie II goes off to pay that gambling
debt the fuse goes are looking into
what's going on and they visit dougie
coop at his office and on the way out I
tries to kill dougie Cooper but is
unsuccessful
that same day Cynthia Knox arrives at
Buckhorn she sees the body and she
called up Colonel Davis to tell him that
the body is actually major breaks Diane
Albert and Gordon along with Tammy all
show up in Yankton they go in Dianne
meets evil coupe later in that same day
evil coop plans his escape by telling
warden Murphy what he knows about mr.
strawberry and the other guy what a
Murphy lets him and ray out that night
and Rayce shoots him at the Pentagon
Colonel Davis calls the FBI after he
hears back from knocks on the 29th of
September the Thursday Richard tried to
kill Mary embassy just she survives we
see Jerry arguing with his foot we see
Lucy here having her lunch as the guys
go outside to try to open up the capsule
for major breaks they find the
information there about the event of
Jackrabbits pilots being two days away
and this is what grounds the date for a
lot of these things because we know that
this happened on the 29th based on the
fact that ten one and ten two or two
days and three days away
later that day sheriff Truman goes over
to the Great Northern gives the Betty
gets in the room key and this is the
evening where we see Bobby and Big Ed
with Norma it's also when we see Hawk
and Truman back at the thing in the map
in Las Vegas on the same day the piece
goes collect the prints up from Doug to
dandy hits Robbie Mitchum in the face
with the remote control
Duncan Todd gets the call from mr. see
evil coupe Ike's arrested dougie cube
goes to have a doctor's appointment
Duncan Todd decides to have Tony
Sinclair go and tells admissions that
it's all because of dougie - Janie
sleep together and mention brothers
decide that they're going to take care
of dougie - in Buckhorn the FBI gang
arrives we see that text message that we
think is from evil coupe - Diane Timmy
does her interview with Phil Hastings
and we get another reference to the same
date to 29th of September Albert goes
out with Constance we see cold drawing
in his room and we see the vision of
Laura as Albert comes over to tell him
about the text that Diane received
somewhere outside of Yankton evil coupe
arrives to where he meets Hutchins
Chantel he sends a text and he makes a
telephone call to Duncan Todd on
September 30th we see try to intercept a
letter for Richard at the same time
Richard Rob's his grandmother Steven is
missing so that's when Becky tries to go
over and shoot him she finds out after
hearing about the robbery and Richard
then asked Beverly out and we meet
Audrey for the first time on the 30th
worrying about Billie back in Las Vegas
Bushnell gives dougie the check to take
out to the Mitchum's Bradley Mitchum has
his dream Mike diverts dougie coot to
buy the cherry pie and that's when the
Mitchum's and dougie coupe become
friends on the same day out in South
Dakota the FBI goes to where the zone
was we see Diane watch Hastings dies at
the hands of a woodsman and then they go
back to the office where they have
coffee and doughnuts and Diane checks
the coordinates on her phone at the bar
now the first of October we haven't seen
in Twin Peaks yet we're still waiting
for that but according to what
everybody's put together in Las Vegas
Sinclair realizes he has to kill dougie
the few skills make a big mistake when
they overlook the data that they get
back on the fingerprints Jani E gets her
car and Sonny Kim gets her his gym set
and Sinclair Tony Sinclair asks for the
poison to try to kill dougie tooth the
next day again this is still on the
first Tammy joins the blue rose task
force Gordon has the French girl over
and
comes in to report on the text messaging
again this will be the same day when
what board and Murphy's killed and evil
coupe shows up at the farm while he's
there he kills ray and Ray ends up in
the waiting room also Richard shows up
in western Montana on that day to see it
all go down
October 2nd this is where it most likely
makes sense that Becky was worried about
Stephen where she gets that call at the
Double R where we see Shelley get the
call from Becky and she tells her to
come over and get pie back in Las Vegas
Anthony tries to poison dougie coupe but
he doesn't go through with it and then
he confesses and that to this point is
all that we've seen now I mentioned that
some of us gray some of it's fuzzy and
so that might just not be correct but it
is a good working outline and a lot of
it does come down to the 29th and how
events are arranged around it the
redditor cow jumped over the m obviously
did a lot of work and looked at all the
clothing that our people are wearing in
various scenes and I can't verify all of
it but it makes a lot of sense when you
look at it as a whole there are some
things that don't seem to fit it all in
Dee's watch is a big one a lot of people
pointed out that it says the tents and
that just doesn't fit any way that you
try to figure it out the Becky stuff is
a little bit sketchy to me it doesn't
make a hundred percent sense but this is
all addressed in the original reddit
post so you could check that stuff out
there I think the biggest thing about
this that stood out to me was I had
assumed that everything that's happened
that we've seen on-screen has been
before the 1st of October because I
expected a large coming together of all
these characters around that date so to
figure out that according to this that
the FBI won't be there on the first and
evil coupe won't be there on the first
that kind of blew my mind a little bit
so this took forever to go through and
I'll just leave it at that please like
the video if you enjoyed it make sure
you let me know in the comments what you
think make sure you visit the actual
thread and give some upload love to One
Flew Over the M because that's a lot of
work that's been going on for some time
make sure you subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already
follow my social media accounts Twitter
Instagram Facebook we can interact over
there thanks for watching guys I'll talk
to you soon